evan is with us in orlando hi evan how
are you
hey dave hey ken thanks for taking my
call guys sure how can we help
i yes my question is i'm wondering if
you guys have ever heard of
a million dollar baby plan yeah it's a
bad whole life policy for kids
okay i was just trying to figure out
because i heard it from my brother and
my alarm bells were going off when you
were telling me whole life and investing
yeah they should go off it's just it's
crap
it's just got a it's got a snazzy name
you know how you're going to get a
million dollars in there you put 2
million in
it's the old joke how do you make a
small fortune in a winery you start with
a large fortune
they're playing on your emotions it is
it is a
great name but the chances of you ending
up with a million dollars in your baby's
whole life policy is almost zero i mean
you would have to put
so stinking much money in there the
rates of return are pitiful
they keep all the money that you put in
for the first three years
it is just a really bad
savings account with a life insurance
company
sucks beyond belief great name
i mean i pulled up one website it's got
a baby standing there
with a fistful of dollars which he's
getting ready to give to the insurance
company
it's so true so
yeah i'm sorry your brother got got had
man tell him to run
well turns out ramsay solutions has had
a million dollar baby plan
since inception it's called the baby
steps yeah well
because if you actually work them out
well you could actually invest money
into your kid's name
529 plan right you become a millionaire
and leave it to your kids
wow there you go that's how you do it
yeah yeah no
there's no free lunch no no no
whole life that i love they always go
it's tax-free growth
yeah not really that's true that's
semantics the only way you get the money
out that you put in
and not pay taxes on is you borrow it
and you pay interest
on your money so let me tell you
something if you put money listen if you
put money in a bank
and you've got 200 000 in a bank and cds
and you go
borrow a hundred thousand dollars out of
that same bank while you're two
and you pledge your 200 000 rcd against
it there's no taxes on that borrowed
money hmm
there's no taxes on borrowed money duh
yeah borrowing money is not a taxable
event
right because there's no taxes you're
but you're borrowing your own stinking
money and paying them interest to get it
out so it's
tax it's tax-free growth
it's an industry that's been screwing
people since yeah
this is the power of marketing language
we've got to wake up
yeah but that's a great integrate title
billion dollar baby
are you kidding me what good parent
doesn't want to get the hell you don't
want
to be a million dollar baby i mean
you're not a parent what kind of parent
wouldn't do that yeah